the Joe Rogan experience myth number two
well I don't say myth I should say rumor
was that this was something from some
sort of a biological weapons thing that
was leaked right because Wuhan is some
area well part of China that they
actually do work on biological weapons
and we've heard that loud and clear and
let me just give a little bit background
aboard in my career back in the early
1990s I got very involved and the whole
area of bio defense and bioterrorism bio
warfare it turned out I was involved
with helping to an interview and get
information from some of the Russian
bioweapon errors after the Wall fell and
Russia collapse we had all these experts
coming out who had been spending their
whole lives making bio weapons and it
became very clear to me this was really
a serious challenge and as part of my
work I spent a lot of time in this area
and I actually through a series of
serendipitous events became a personal
advisor His Majesty King Hussein of
Jordan before he died on this topic I
got really into it I wrote a book that
was published on 9/11 of 2000 called
living terrors what our country needs so
those five becoming bioterrorist
catastrophe and I think I bought eight
of the twelve copies that were sold in
that year afterwards and then when 9/11
happened of course then it became really
prominent and then I went on to serve on
a group here in the United States that
was basically the National Science
Advisory Board of biosecurity safety
issues so I've had a lot of experience
in this area and so I bring that to the
table and I tell you there is no
evidence whatsoever that this is a bio
weapon or that it was accidentally
released from the wuhan lab today with
the genetics we have on these viruses
and how we can do testing we can almost
date them almost like carbon testing you
know so radiocarbon you want to know how
old a block is or something like that
this thing clearly jumped from an animal
species probably the third week of
November to humans and penguins you know
the scaly anteater like animals are very
good source because we have
coronaviruses just like those in these
animals and it got into a human so you
know we've surely had a lot of
challenges with that but I don't believe
that there's any evidence linking those
two I want an intense
release or an accidental release or that
it's an engineered bug is not my friend
Duncan and I did a show back in 2012 ish
somewhere around there with sci-fi where
we went to the CDC in Galveston and we
talked to them about that very thing and
they added the real concern the real
concern is just actual diseases it's not
man-made diseases it's just disease
that's exactly I mean look you know we
could not have crafted a virus like this
to do what it's doing I mean we don't
have the creative imagination or the
skill set if somebody said okay I want
to find a virus that will take out a lot
of people okay this one mother nature
does it so much better than we could
ever do it and you know whether it was
Ebola whether it's this one or it's
antibiotic resistance any of these
things I mean you know and I were
talking about the Finch for chronic
wasting disease to be a problem for
humans you know mother nature is doing
it pretty well in her own
[Applause]